we just have now uh yeah just under
three minutes until we get those exit
poll results yeah what will you be
looking for okay i've just kind of
listed i think the four most important
things so let's go obviously with number
one who's top of course that's the first
question that we that we'll be looking
for um
do the conservatives manage to stay top
um or
do the social democrats manage to
overtake them in a surprise victory
second question what's the gap between
them
if there's a bigger gap between them
then that will have a big impact on the
coalition
talks moving ahead we've heard about
some of the potential combinations
fiendishly complicated
the bigger the gap between the top two
parties the more authority that top
party has to kind of set the agenda with
forming a coalition
third question what's the gap between
the greens and the free democrats so the
greens of course we've seen that they've
put it forward a a
chancellor candidate they're one of the
kind of three top runners but the three
democrats also we just heard from simon
there quite a powerful party influential
party could be king makers what's the
gap between them what's their relative
power that will be really important also
for the horse trading of the coalitions
going forward final question do the left
party get into parliament at all as we
just heard uh from hans there there's
this five percent hurdle that they have
to get over and they've been doing
pretty badly they've been close to that
five percent if they don't get in that
scrambles the arithmetic all over again
yeah well we have just around a minute
30 left we're literally counting down
the clock at this moment so just remind
our viewers richard why this is really
such a momentous election for germany
why there's so much at stake here well
angela merkel is leaving office and
i mean we just saw in the in our talk
show with max just earlier anybody who
was watching that this is an election
that's not just being watched in germany
it's being watched around the world
because angela merkel i mean she's been
been like 16 years in in germany she's
far and away the most experienced and
powerful politician in europe suddenly
she's leaving the stage
also she has a global stature and just
think of it for 16 years in power that's
double the longest presidency that's
permitted on the american system so this
kind of you know 16 years in a
democratic country is almost
unprecedented leaving the stage what
happens next it's a huge moment of
uncertainty and a huge moment really
setting the cause for the for the next
few years not just in germany but in
europe how do you think angela merkel is
looking at these elections tonight well
didn't she say recently she's looking
forward to
to having a nap
so
so yeah but she's thrown in her lot
behind army lasher as we were just
seeing in our reporting earlier so she
she has kind of weighed in on the
election in the last few weeks well we
are counting down as you said these
those are the important things to look
at we're going to get these exit poll
results in just about 10 seconds now
and they'll give us a clearer picture
let's hope because the last polls were
very close so let's take a look at what
flashes up now
[Music]
well we said it was a nail biter and it
is a nail biter
let's see if we can get those numbers up
on the screen to show you who might have
a good shot of taking over from angela
merkel's 16 years in powers
it is a dead heat
the top two parties cdu csu and the spd
center right center left at 25 right now
i should caution you this is an exit
poll this is a representation of what
the results might be this is by no means
the final result but right now we're
looking at a tie between the top two
parties the greens down to 15
more than they did in 2017 but less than
they are hoping for
and look down here the left party just
squeaks by it looks like into to have
any seats at all in the german
parliament this is
this is this is where we are right now
we're gonna have a lot more updates i
think we should turn it right over sumi
what do you think people are in the
field and we should uh hear what people
are celebrating or not yeah we're going
to do that in just a second i just
quickly want to get your take on this
richard because this is exactly what you
said one of your points to look out for
how much of a difference is there
so far looking at exit polls zero zero
zero
if this is the result that we end up
with at the end of this evening th this
is going to be a very very difficult
situation to form a coalition um
they are yeah it really scrambles things
um if if both parties are on an equal
footing a huge number of questions
raised really like who has the advantage
in trying to put together a government
um so yeah this is a fascinating result
real
basically political deadlock and it does
as you said really reflect the polls
that we saw leading up to today yeah it
does i mean we've had a narrowing of the
polls uh in recent days there was this
period a couple of weeks ago where olaf
schultz and the social democrats
overtook the conservatives and this was
a big surprise but things have tightened
in in recent days so so if this is borne
out then the polling you know there are
a lot of elections recently in many
parts of the world where polling
has has been wide off the mark if this
is borne out then the polling seems to
have been pretty close it really is
remarkable we should say the two top
parties the center left center right
really in a dead heat uh we're gonna go
right to uh michele kufna who as we said
is with the conservatives and misaela
you were watching that big reveal on the
screen
at the election party of the
conservatives tell us what the reaction
was there
it was absolutely static it was a moment
of disbelief
and what they saw up on the screen there
here at the cdu party headquarters is
the scenario if one had had to draw up a
scenario that is the most inconclusive
it would have been exactly that with the
social democrats and the conservative
cdu csu both having 25 percentage points
and question marks of whether the left
party will actually make it into the
german bundestag would could which could
prove to be a huge factor in coalition
building so very early days here
it clearly is a defeat um for the
conservative cdu csu party it's lost
several percentage points it's the worst
result
in its post-war history
so yes it's a defeat and it could still
be turned into a governing coalition
option depending on all of those postal
ballots being counted because let's not
forget these are only exit polls this is
voters being asked to vote again
anonymously once they've left the
polling booth yeah that's right we are
still waiting for those first results
that we're going to get michelle but
just quickly i mean so our viewers
understand this these results if they
stand uh would essentially mean that we
could still see i'm in leicester of
course become the chancellor
yes they could and particularly because
of germany's voting system that would
currently despite equal percentage
points give the conservative
cdu csu three more seats in the
bundestag but at this point it's way too
imprecise to enter this into the formula
and believe that this is actually a
conclusive result so a slight advantage
still for the conservative cdu csu
angela mackel's party but a huge success
for those social democrats who could
still pull ahead it's completely
inconclusive at this moment in time
you